So,
you have
effectively recognized the famous New Zealand Academy,
which is 1 cry,
uh.
Imminently a warrior.
Here are some words,
they'll, uh.
Show up,
it's death,
it's life,
uh.
This is the hairy man,
the a. K.
anchors players in their Maori past.
But anyway,
you have to say things as they are,
it is nevertheless 1 concentrate of virilism,
of warlike rhetoric,
in short,
everything you want to deconstruct.
Do you mind if it's that much,
expected,
that this
this war cry is so glorified,
expected by 1,000,000 people?
If the question you're asking me is,
is it, uh.
1 world where one glorifies and one highlights,
uh.
Virilistic codes to that extent,
and that we pass completely under silence
everything that is,
uh.
Women's competition,
because we saw it,
uh.
We could talk about the soccer world cup,
uh. Female,
et cetera. Yes,
Well, I mean, yes,
when I have,
when I saw Emmanuel Macron
go down 1 bottle of beer
in 1 locker room,
no,
it's also women who play rugby.
Yeah, well,
you saw them there on uh.
They do the Aka.
And you,
and you saw them there on uh.
Television screens.
You saw on their world cup,
you saw their salary,
you've seen it. So no,
we're not going to lie to each other,
in fact, we can.
To think, yes, there is,
there are teams of women very good.
But that,
we will not lie about the fact that there is 1
profound inequality
woman man in sport.
We're not going to lie about the fact that the
men's sport is
highly valued compared to women's sports.
We're not going to lie about the fact that
the codes of the sport are codes which are
adapted to men.
So uh,
we actually stop lying to ourselves about it.
Yes, it's 1,
it's 1 competition,
uh
which is obviously
uh that highlights ultra virist codes.
I mean,
there's no subject matter about that.
That's why I won't watch the games.
I'll tell you what,
uh,
I watch 1 from time to time for
just be able to answer reporter questions.